soir hassan alaoui ravis de vous
accueillir en direct sur cette antenne
alors pour d'un qu'on comprenne
quels sont les objectifs officiels mais
aussi officieux de ces exercices
d'ailleurs spectaculaire de la part de
l'armée algérienne tout à fait vous avez
raison de spécifier les deux ternes
officielles et officieuses convialité
c'est une rhétorique classique au régime
algérien je dirais plutôt à l'armée la
titulaire si vous voulez 2 du pouvoir en
algérie et c'est lié à un contexte
particulier de ces derniers temps que
l'algérie est en train de vivre je me
permettrais de dire dramatiquement sans
jeter la pierre
ces convois qu' il ya un président de la
république algérienne qui très malade
qui se fait soigner en allemagne qui
n'est rentré que pour quelques jours en
algérie pour en fait entériner la loi de
finances et d'autres broutilles qui est
retourné dans le camp en algérie vous
avez un mouvement de retour et de
libération en l'occurrence de l'ancien
général à l'ena qui était vraiment
persona non grata pendant un moment qui
est maintenant de retour officiel plutôt
officieux si vous voulez on attend de
voir et vous avez aussi la libération
d'un d'autres généraux donc par tag
médine qui était aussi les patrons du
renseignement algérien et en même temps
vous avez un climat délétère avec le
mouvement en irak qui ne qui n'arrêtent
pas si vous voulez vraiment donne une
image d'une algérie qui plutôt instable
en plus de ça je dirais que la
constitution qui a été votée évidemment
améliorée notamment en son article pour
permettre à l'armée algérien d'agir à
l'extérieur de ses frontières
ensuite la crise économique très
aggravées avec une baisse je ne dirais
pas récurrentes mais
pandémie pardonnez moi l'expression ces
cas de le dire si vous voulez une baisse
du prix du pétrole
et tout cela si vous voulez ça donnait
un contexte mouvementé
en tout cas c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire très très très inquiétante et donc
cela arrive à un moment aussi où le
maroc n'est ce pas engrange c'est le cas
de le dire
des succès sur plan diplomatique et même
militaire puisque le 13 novembre dernier
l'armée marocaine est allé pacifiquement
jeu le sully un sens en ce sens des
gammes sans rien mais en tout cas pour
évacuer si vous venez de le point le
point d'ancrage si vous voulez entre la
mauritanie et le maroc où il ya un
passage important de véhicules de
commerce qui vont vers l'afrique si vous
voulez qui vient d'europe qui passent
pas là le polisario avait décidé de les
bloquer pendant des semaines
mais le maroc a attendu patiemment puis
il a fini par se résoudre à cette
solution de l'évacuer sans anicroche
sans coup férir comme on dit et donc la
voie est libre pour si vous voulez tous
les transports qui arrivent d'europe et
du nord pour aller jusqu'en afrique
et n'oubliez pas que le but de cette
histoire de gainax c'est tout simplement
de couper le maroc de ses racines
africaines ce que l'algérie n'est ce pas
à s'est efforcé de faire depuis
en vérité depuis 45 ans que la
croissance y aller moi parce qu'il aime
il ya plusieurs questions évidemment ce
genre d'événement il ya toujours des
symboles et l'armée algérienne pour la
première fois exhibé un avion américain
de reconnaissance électronique
c'est le seul armements non russes en
démonstration vous avez une idée de la
raison pour laquelle tu as c'est un
avion qu'on appelle le beechcraft 1900
elle mais ça n'est ce pas il est connu
le maroc possède si vous voulez
permettez détonne je veux dire de
beaucoup de la viande de ce genre en
fait il faire quand ils ne sont pas si
vous voulez améliorer je veux dire quand
il ne comporte pas de matériel
sophistiqué place et a posteriori
ils sont l'innovation pour des missions
de voyage de
personnel politique et militaire pour au
maroc
donc cela si vous voulez ce n'apprécions
pas dit oh les forces armées marocaines
rôle et à l'état-major marocain parce
que ses avis
nous avons l'habitude de les voir et
donc ils représentent systématiquement
aucun danger pour l'homme et donc ces
faits uniquement ce signal est donné
pour que je veux dire rassurer le peuple
algérien comme quoi l'armée algérienne
n'a ne craint rien elle est forte et les
armes et tutti canti et en ce moment on
invoque un avocat tort je considère on
invoque l'histoire de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
les trafiquants de drogue et bien sûr la
nuit classiques historiques qui quitte
aussi un bouc émissaire c'est le baroque
alors on aimait devra qui interviennent
dans un contexte tendu on le sait après
l'adhésion de la présidence américaine
un train au plan d'autonomie proposé par
le maroc sur le sahara est ce qu'on sait
c'est joe biden va renier ou non cette
décision prise par le président sortant
trump qui a reconnu
justement la marocanité du sahara
si tu mets à question récurrente et à
laquelle je veux dire sur laquelle se
sont jetés les médias algériens parce
que tout ce qui les intéresse c'est de
savoir si le nouveau président américain
de bagdad va ou non renier la position
de son prédécesseur la reconnaissance du
sahara marocain
et ben moi je pense que c'est une une
fausse question elle est d'autant plus
faux ce que de toute manière le bail
donne c'est un démocrate
alors qu'ils soient démocrates ou
républicains les relations entre le
maroc et les etats unis sont des
relations qui ont deux siècles et demi
depuis que en 1777 le maroc a été le
tout premier pays à reconnaître la jeune
république des états unis la jeune
république américaine parce qu'il y a eu
à un événement important c'est que
george washington avait demandé au roi
ou insultant
d'intercéder pour libérer des bateaux de
commerce américain qui mouille et dans
la mer méditerranée à gibraltar et qui
était attaqué systématiquement par les
ottomans les bateaux au tendon et donc
le maroc hit et à intervenir à libérer
les américains et depuis c'est une
relation privilégiée
le marron qualité l'allié des etats-unis
pendant la première et la deuxième
guerre mondiale quand et si bien que on
a commencé à dire que le maroc si
l'allié des alliés parce que lilith les
marocains les soldats marocains sont
allés en italie sont allés avant monte
cassino sont allés en france en
allemagne
ils ont combattu et même en indochine
donc il était l'alliée des alliés et ça
justifie un petit peu si vous voulez sa
relation privilégiée avec les américains
qui lance qui ont intégré le maroc dans
le système de l'otan c'est un cetain
c'est un fait je veux le dire est
irréversible que personne ne changera si
bien que maintenant la question qui se
pose
by dell va-t-il renoncer il n'a pas le
temps maidana d'autre choix face à à
fouetter en l'occurrence il voulait
réconcilier les américains au nom de
même faire réussir et de cohésion qui
devenu difficile parce que l'amérique
est partagé vous n'arrêtez pas de toutes
les télévisions de 10 et la mairie
elle est divisée aujourd'hui le premier
devoir de gaytten c'est justement de
rétablir la confiance et la cohésion
sociale et politique
les américains merci beaucoup hassan
alaoui je rappelle aux directeurs de
publication de maromme diplomatique
spécialiste des affaires maghrébines
merci et d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur rt france